avec nous la ministre du développement
économique mélanie joly bonsoir est ce
que la mesure aujourd'hui va sauver les
restaurants les salons de coiffure les
fleuristes les petits commerces
est-ce que ça va vraiment permettre
d'éviter la faillite à ces entreprises
c'est certainement pour les entreprises
qui était seul tout en bon état avant la
halle à créer ça va faire une grosse
différence et ça c'est vraiment j'ai eu
l'occasion de parler autant à différents
entrepreneurs des chambres de commerce
déccélération chambre de commerce le
conseil du patronat partout à travers le
québec le pays et c'est ce qu'on nous
réclame est donc essentiellement 75% de
réduction des loyers pour nos pme
et ça ça va vraiment aider avec les
autres les autres nous sommes
aujourd'hui qu'on a annoncé la
fédération des chambres de commerce du
québec disent un peu restrictif quand
même soixante dix pour cent de baisse de
revenus pour les entreprises et
l'interruption également d'activités il
ya quand même des entreprises qui ont
poursuivi leur activité par exemple en
ligne en se transformant est ce qu'elles
vont avoir accès à ce programme sur les
loyers commerciaux
mais en fait c'est soit qu'elle doit
d'avoir cessé leurs activités ou jusqu'à
ce en fait où au moins 70% de pertes de
revenus donc très certainement les
restaurateurs par exemple qui continue à
faire en sorte d'avoir des certaines
activités parce que l on les
restaurateurs ont des livraisons des
fois récit s'est jamais autant
qu'auparavant
mieux une baisse de revenus drastique et
donc on pense qu'on est capable de
combler quand même énormément cas dont
et comme je dis ça sans nationale à la
subvention la masse salariale auprès de
40 mais paul tison et moyennes
entreprises et je voudrais aussi une
quête initiatique qui a c'est un petit
peu plus sous silence mais ses
étonnements l'appui de déco québec le
développement économique canada pour les
régions du québec qui guident agences
dont je m'occupe qui est vrai que là
aussi pour signer les entreprises qui
demandent ses traces
c'est important les restaurants sont
très très très inquiet on avait jérôme
ferrer hier soir à rdi économie joue
faire un peu attendre un petit extrait
de ce qu'ils nous disaient
restaurant ce n'est pas juste une
business c'est un patrimoine culturel
c'est un patrimoine culinaire d'un
peuple d'une nation
on est les ambassadeurs d'artisans de
producteurs quand la restauration va
plonger c'est tout un univers agricole
qui va plonger en même temps sa cécité
rue est ce qu'on va sortir amoché de
tout cela est ce qu'on va perdre
beaucoup de nos entreprises et nous
restaurant justement qui représente
cette culture là mais je suis d'accord
avec ce que tu faisais un radis c'est
tout un patrimoine culinaire c'est ses
propres notre culture à montréal au
québec ont extrêmement fiers de notre
gastronomie et en tant que ministre qui
est encore aussi en charge du tourisme
qui tue secteur la restauration il vote
soit qu' on veut en faire encore et
toujours plus et est bien entendu
l'objectif de la mesure d'aujourd'hui
directement pour venir en aide à nos
restaurateurs et à nos petits
commerçants parce que si je pense si on
n'était pas arrivé avec une entente avec
les problèmes sur la question des loyers
commerciaux
mais on en rêve défigurer la majorité
nos rues principales dans mon quartier à
montréal à québec mais aussi parfois
faveur de plus une stabilité
maintenant si la mesure n'est pas assez
large
ça m'a fait plaisir d'entendre un point
de vue à date on était en mesure de
vraiment s'adapter au fur à mesure que
ont parlé avec nos entrepreneurs
d'ailleurs on est rendus on disait en
début d'émission à 3,117 milliards des
directs liquidités crédit aux
entreprises
est ce qu'une limite un moment donné à
tout ce qu'on peut faire
mais pour répondre à votre question mais
aussi à la question précédente tout ce
qu'on fait présentement gérant par un
impact sur la relance économique
plus on est capable d'aider nos
entreprises à traverser le pont et est
ce qu'on les rencontre l'autre côté de
la rive
plus on va être capable de par la suite
avoir une économie saine une économie
qui diversifient économie qui est
capable de faire des emplois a partout à
travers à travers les laitières en
septembre des calculs mais aussi au sein
de
de nos grandes villes et nos régions
donc je pense que présentement on a une
réaction au canada qui est sensiblement
la même que dans le g7 et le g20
ce matin j'avais un appel avec tous les
milieux du tourisme du g20 est très
certainement pas être fiers de notre
réponse - et en démon du leadership à ce
niveau comme ministre du développement
économique du tourisme également et dans
les régions notamment est-ce qu'il faut
rouvrir plus rapidement à saguenay
à rimouski à rivière du loup à
sherbrooke à trois rivières est ce qu'il
faut aller plus vite c'est une question
qui va défendre vraiment de des conseils
de nos experts en santé publique
il ya beaucoup de régions moins touchées
que les grandes villes et qui se disent
bien là on n'a presque pas de chaos pour
beaucoup de cas est ce qu'on peut ouvrir
cet été parce qu'ils voyaient il venait
d'avoir des touristes qui va qui vont se
promener cet été est ce que les régions
devrait pouvoir ouvrir plus rapidement
mais je dirais que comme un c'est une
question d expertise de santé publique
et deuxièmement je pense qu'ils savent
être un équilibre ça va être un
équilibre entre le fait de pop propager
davantage le virus et en même temps ne
pas affaiblir davantage l'économie de
nos régions parce qu'elle les a fait
perdre surtout avec toutes les questions
liées aux travailleurs et aux crèches
saisonniers et donc au niveau
touristique et une relative instigation
du connu l'été les super important dans
nos régions et donc on va essayer pas
peu de soutenir nos économies
soutenez aussi le tourisme local au
départ régional mauvaise personne en
concertation avec avec des particules
mélanie joly
merci beaucoup ça va faire plaisir bonne
journée